DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don
Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today, my guest is Alex Moore,
founder of Baydin.
Alex was on our last show.
And it was so interesting that
we invited him back again for
another show.
Today, we're going to talk
about raising money from
friends and family, angels,
venture capital, business
models, and that sort of thing--
how you get going.
So Alex, did you raise money
from friends and family?
Did you take the traditional
route-- friends and family,
angels, VCs?
ALEX MOORE: My friends and
family are all pretty broke--
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX MOORE: --so I
actually went--
Baydin actually went
straight from
self-funding to angel funding.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
So how did you make the
pitch to angels?
How did you find the angels
that would be interested?
ALEX MOORE: For us, the thing
that made the pitch work the
best was having traction
numbers.
So when we actually--
when we went to raise our round,
we'd already launched
our product, Boomerang.
We already had, I think, about
70,000 users using it.
And we already had enough usage,
enough engaged users
that we figured we'd be
able to eventually
make money from it.
DON DODGE: So you bootstrapped
building the initial product,
getting it launched and
get to 70,000 users
before you raised money?
ALEX MOORE: Right.
DON DODGE: How long did
that take you, and
how much did it cost?
ALEX MOORE: Well before--
well, if you don't count the
stuff we were working on
before we pivoted, it was about
six months of work to
get the product out there and
launched and start getting
some users for it.
From a cost standpoint, it was
mostly just keeping myself and
the rest of the team fed and
housed and sheltered and all
those things--
so basically, whatever it takes
to keep people alive for
six months.
DON DODGE: So how did you do
your initial user acquisition
and get to 70,000 users?
That's a lot of users.
ALEX MOORE: Well, we kind of
caught lightning in a bottle
when we launched.
We got one article that
then turned into
several other articles.
And it was mostly press-driven
at that point--
so just getting that initial
press and converting it.
And then we also did a really
good kind of a predecessor to
the launch sites that people
have, where you can tweet to
get ahead in the line.
So we did that also, much more
manually and much more ad hoc.
So you could either sign up to
enter your email address to be
notified when we were ready, or
you could tweet and move to
the front of the line.
DON DODGE: So you encouraged
potential users to tweet about
Baydin, and then that
would get them up?
So you sort of gamified the
acquisition process?
ALEX MOORE: Yeah,
a little bit.
And we found that if we said,
you can use it in 24 hours if
you tweet, or it might be a week
or so before we can get
the server capacity up-- and in
fairness, we needed to see
all the servers.
So we really couldn't let
everybody in all at once.
But gamifying it definitely
helped us.
DON DODGE: So Facebook did
something similar, where you
had to be from a
certain school.
You had to have a Harvard edu
address or a Stanford edu
address to get into Facebook.
And they created these
waiting lists.
And that waiting list and
exclusivity sort of encouraged
more people to get going.
Is that sort of what you did by
saying, tweet about it, and
maybe you can get in?
ALEX MOORE: Yeah, I
think it helped.
I remember back at MIT, when
Facebook launched, we were, I
think, the third school
to get it.
The thing that made it work
so well is they kept their
servers alive.
Everybody was on Friendster,
everybody was on Myspace,
everybody was on six of these
things, but the only one that
kept their servers up reliably
was Facebook.
And so I think it's one of
those things where server
capacity and exclusivity worked
hand-in-hand to make
things work well for them.
DON DODGE: So let's get back to
how you made the decision
to raise money and where
you went to get it.
How did you decide
to go to angels?
And how did you get introduced
to those angels?
ALEX MOORE: We went with angels,
because I was running
out of money.
And like I said, friends
and family weren't
really a big option.
We got introduced to the
angels largely--
well, AngelList helped.
It was way back in the early
days for AngelList.
But that was sort of how
we sourced them.
We went to AngelList, we looked
at them, and we found
out who we wanted to be--
who we wanted to meet.
And then it tended to be long
intro chains for us that made
a big difference.
So we'd meet one person.
They'd say, well, this isn't
right for me, but I know who
it is right for.
And then we'd get an
intro to them.
And then eventually, we'd end
up with the people who ended
up investing.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
Did you approach VCs?
ALEX MOORE: We did.
At the time, we thought we were
a little early for it.
We didn't necessarily know
whether we had the kind of
thing where it needed to be a
billion-dollar company or bust.
We weren't sure what the right
shape of our company was going
to be, so we decided to go
with angels instead.
DON DODGE: So you raised a
little bit of angel money.
That got you funding for what,
six months or a year?
ALEX MOORE: About 18 months.
DON DODGE: 18 months.
And at what point did you
decide, oh, we need to have a
revenue model, and we need to be
generating cash rather than
spend all that 18 months just
focused on building features
and innovation?
When did you make that choice?
ALEX MOORE: It was about six
months after we raised our
angel round.
And we looked at our numbers
and our growth, and we saw
basically polynomial growth,
like I talked about last show.
We saw that it wasn't the kind
of inherently viral product,
where users mattered
more than money.
And so we figured, well, let's
see if we can get a revenue
model in place.
And if anything, that would
probably help us if we need to
raise money later.
And fortunately, we were lucky
enough to not need to.
We reached profitability
when we turned
on the revenue model.
DON DODGE: So many start-up
entrepreneurs, when they're
faced with this problem, they
say the answer is, develop
more features.
If we have more features, if we
have more innovation, we'll
attract more users, and that
will eventually lead to growth
and profit.
Others, like yourself, say no,
we need to focus on a revenue
model and start generating at
least a little cash so that we
extend our runway.
So how did you go through
that decision process?
ALEX MOORE: Well, for us,
it was kind of a--
what really triggered it for
us is we looked at our
product, and we said, well, if
this isn't going to make any
money for us, this
probably isn't--
it's not viral.
It's the kind of thing
where we have to be--
we know we're adding
a lot of value.
Can we turn it into money?
And we really wanted to answer
that question for ourselves
before we poured another
12 months of
development effort into it.
I think had things-- had it not
worked out, we would have
had to make a decision between,
do we add more
features to make it work, or
do we need to pivot again?
But it worked out.
DON DODGE: So how about today?
You've raised your
angel money.
You have a revenue model.
You have users.
You're at cash flow break
even or profitable.
So what's next?
Do you decide to go for venture
capital and shoot for
the moon, or are you going
for the steady
growth and cash flow?
ALEX MOORE: The timing for us to
raise venture capital would
be when it could massively
accelerate the business.
So right now we're doing very
nice growth on our own.
And we haven't found a channel
that looks like we need
venture capital money
to saturate it.
Every channel we've found, it
seems like we can make work
with our current budget.
So when we find an opportunity
to acquire customers that
needs a bunch of VC money,
that's what we'd want to start
looking at that.
DON DODGE: So what about
your angel investors?
They put their money
how long ago?
ALEX MOORE: About
two years ago.
DON DODGE: So they
are two years in.
Investors expect a return
at some point.
So how do you deal with
your investors?
Do you tell them, hey, we're
going to be cash flow
positive, and we'll distribute
cash, or we're going to have
an exit at some point?
Or how do you deal with your
angel investors now?
ALEX MOORE: It's not too hard to
do when you're making money
and growing nicely.
They've been very supportive.
They're very--
the investors we have are very
hands-on guys who are awesome
to work with.
And they've been generally
supportive of what we've been
doing, because the growth is
there, and we continue to
invest and do innovations
and things like that.
So it hasn't really been
a challenge for us.
It's just been, every month we
send out updates, and they
say, hey, it looks good.
Keep doing it.
DON DODGE: How about
employees?
Have you had to add employees?
And if so, how do you attract
them and tell them the stock
option story?
ALEX MOORE: Definitely.
We've grown the team from
three up to eight now.
And for us, the thing that makes
Baydin a great place to
work is the environment and
is what we're working on.
One of the nice things about
working in email is that you
are your own customer also.
So part of what makes it--
helps us attract customer-- or
helps us attract employees is
that we can recruit from
our customers also--
so people who think, hey, this
is really cool stuff, maybe I
should work on this.
DON DODGE: Hm.
Great story.
Well, thank you.
I would like to invite you
to try out Google Cloud.
We have a special offer for
Google Root Access users.
You have a $2,000 credit if you
use Cloud to develop your
application.
The information for how to get
this credit will appear on
your screen.
Thank you very much
for joining us and
see you next time.